The premier U.S. example of a large
scale, in this case statewide,
centralized health information exchange,
is the Indiana Health
Information Exchange, or IHIE.
Its Indiana Network for Patient Care
creates a single virtual community-wide
health record and delivers more than a
million transactions per day from a data
warehouse that contains 5 billion
pieces of clinical data for
some 10 million patients.
Docs 4 Docs provides a web portal
to make it easy for physicians to
obtain documents like lab test results
or reports on images they've ordered.
Quality Health First is
a population-based quality reporting
system we'll look at in Lesson 8.
Image Zone is an image repository that
allows physicians to see any image done
on a patient anywhere in the exchange
area from their office computer.
ACO Services is the newest
offering of IHIE that
provides tailored management tools for
that environment.
Providing these services means
aggregating data from many sources that
are not inherently interoperable.
The key component of this
diagram is data governance,
a sophisticated engine that bridges
differences in data syntax and
semantics across these sources to create
a single database in a standardized
format, as though everyone were using
the same electronic records system.
This screenshot from the Indiana Network
for Patient Care illustrates that.
Here, a single patient's
data from diverse sources
is presented to a provider as though
it all came from a single record.
It's even formatted
similarly to a typical EMR.